the first selfie stick ban is here god
bless america right on Coachella's list
of rules in big capital letters raids no
selfie sticks Coachella isn't the only
music event of a mistake Lollapalooza
has taken a stance against the stick
saying its rules and regulations that
GoPro attachments like sticks selfie
sticks and monopods are not allowed
alright so we've done a bunch on social
media of course when we talk about
selfie sticks they drive me [ __ ]
crazy I just can't explain it we're all
attached to our phones I know it's
ironic that me for as much as I use my
phone and all that that someone else the
way they do it right we're drive me this
crazy yeah you want to add your selfie
stick glad you're taking this out to get
a second can we Instagram that somebody
grabbed a bat or a minor repairs scoping
out um but that we live in such a
culture of that and now we're seeing it
where people are literally just walking
around with something in front we're in
Truman you were born with two selfie
sticks why do you need to let go but I
saw people in Times Square with a selfie
stick and it was driving me nuts because
one you're not paying to see your
surroundings you're doing this and like
whacking people in the head and it's
like it's bad enough like I see people
doing it it's like I can't tell if
they're blind or like ugly take a selfie
to the right or there's a spot there's a
phone is here that takes it anyway
there's another idiot like walking
around what they're like why do you need
to take Celt like the museum's just
bandham yeah but you can't even take him
i think it's the met or the moment one
of the museum's it's like you're gonna
knock over some like 10,000 year old
face cuz you guys want to take a selfie
with the Mona Lisa so much like yeah I
have I totally agree like so we live in
this culture where clearly like we're
making everything about ourselves all
the time I'm really trying not to take
selfies especially you always see people
taking selfies when they're surrounded
by other people there used to be you
could just ask someone to take a picture
of you right have a perfectly fine
picture but now like you they want this
idea this thing is everything that
social media is leading to just like
it's just ego ego ego right like is that
just where this is all going that's a
huge part of it that's a huge part of
but that's I don't think that's a new
thing
I think it's just that we have the
technology now to allow it yeah I mean
if you look at like core American
principles of kind of like manifest
destiny like God gave me the west of the
United States and just like I earned
this because like we have this very
individual of society you compare us to
Asian societies to other societies from
the east and like across the board
they're hilarious studies where kids in
New York or I don't even know if it's
New York but like American kids take
these exams where they are asked are you
smarter than X percentage of the other
people and the number is ridiculously
writes like I am smarter than seventy
percent of my peers then you ask the
same kids in China and they're like ten
percent but the kids in China are like
significantly smarter exams they do so
much better like you can't be smarter
than ninety percent of your peers when
you're making an f in your classes yeah
yeah think you are right that's the
culture we live so then what do you make
of this that this clearly isn't just an
American thing though because people are
doing this all over the world I think
it's I think it's a big part of the fact
that we now get to walk around with a 10
megapixel camera everywhere we go yeah
and we can take a photo at any time we
well like you used to have to take a
picture wine the thing click take it to
the rite aid in the local store wait a
few days from the kid develop and they
come back now you had to do it your own
dude yeah you have to like right that
would be really old days you got instant
photos everywhere you go and the another
thing that really like gets under my
skin is the fact that people call them
selfies when there's like three people
in it like that it's in the dictionary
now that's not a selfie if there's you
and your four friends that's not a
sellout you truly are a writer because
only a writer would get this though I
bet it's a groupie at best also you see
it all the time on the news you see
hilarious like selfie if someone's on
your like that's just a photo yeah it's
just a picture of them together little
place and it's not even the picture them
doing it it's just them together taking
your photo and they're surrounded by
people that could have taken the picture
of them right a photographer took like
when Obama was at Mandela's memorial and
he took the picture with a in which
country I don't remember but yeah all
the reports are like Obama in an
appropriate selfie with three other
people you're like come on you're the
new
yeah like at least call it what it is a
photo wow you still expect the news to
say things right way it is I'm a
hopeless believer that one day we'll get
it right but we won't yeah I admit
something all right which is I think
tells you that a i'm old and B I'm
totally anti-social I've never seen a
selfie stick in evidence night one level
around here yeah had a kinda like a
really touristy place I guess so I guess
so time square now they have people on
the corners with tables full of selfie
sticks just like selling selfie sticks I
didn't realize what a big issue this
actually was because like I would never
in a [ __ ] million years like duct
tape my phone to like a broom document
my life i guess that people do that on a
regular basis yes they believe 82 it's
like it's douchebaggery cannot be
stopped especially when you can purchase
douche bag accessories it's a it's a
marketing scheme really kind of
douchebaggery be stuck let us know in
the comments right elbow